maintenant passons à l'émission
d'aujourd'hui nous avons un nouveau
titre à cette émission puisque
maintenant notre émission s'appelle la
caméra explore le temps nous avons voulu
élargir notre formule nous avons voulu
essayer de vous faire revivre tous les
mois soit un grand événement historique
soit une page d'histoire et vous y faire
assister un peu comme si vous y étiez
eh bien je voudrais une même rassuré nos
téléspectateurs certains nos
téléspectateurs et également certains
journalistes que nous remercions qui ont
cru que les énigmes étaient mortes
en fait elles ne sont pas mortes et dans
le cadre même de la présente émission
périodiquement nous ressusciterons
certains problèmes mystérieux mais
pourquoi dans cette nouvelle série
pourquoi
pour la première émission de cette
nouvelle série avons-nous choisi
napoléon un mari valeska et bien parce
que je crois qu'il est évident que
napoléon et là des hommes dominants de
l'histoire et il est évident également
que son caractère est indéchiffrable
chaque mois par et une thèse différente
sur napoléon favorable ou défavorable
or comment un homme se dévoile t-il le
mieux
et bien c'est sans doute quand il est
amour oui mais il s'agit d'abord de
savoir si napoléon a été amoureux